[Music]
did you actually hit repeat no it's just
me I'm doing the intro but I'm doing it
with my in real-time versus video right
the performance amazing good morning my
club and non mod club everyone out there
on YouTube because it's a quarantine
month so we're giving away everything
for free
oh if you've enjoyed this if you've
enjoyed spending your time with us go to
a lot of credit I come / mug Club
entering the promo code quarantine and
you get $30 off that's a big deal this
is the last week it is and it's going to
culminate in the in the livestream on
Thursday a few hours but we were going
to do the press briefing and then fact
check CNN turns out they might not do
the press briefing that's what I hear
echoing hears it pops Crowder's mic
isn't on yet is it right good we have a
popper Crowder's gonna be in here a
little bit later what are we talking
about
a couple of things namely that corona is
not not a hoax not a hole right at all
no but you were hopes by the media oh
yeah a lot of you will be talking about
Joe Biden and in all the rape oh all the
rape showed a jovial and then and then
more I didn't do it our way the cover-up
of the rape yeah because you know what
they say about rape the worst thing
about the rape is is that it's the
actual rape but then the show is that
they lie about the rape right is the
cover-up that's a very common saying
yeah it's very it's a long one yeah not
on a bumper sticker with Joe Biden the
hypocrisy is pretty bad yes but the rape
was worse yeah or any of a surprise and
by the way you can subscribe of course
iTunes Android anywhere podcasts are
sold or not sold and crowder bits is
available on YouTube right now for Lily
extra clips of course live chat only
from local members if you're watching
there to at the blaze TV right now we
will be reading some chats later use
your name put you'll have a good we s
yeah great I did great we can help with
allergies though oh wow so you should
get a great weekend but yeah first thing
you mention is allergy
yeah I'm saying I've had a great week
and powered through I went down
pica joke peek what I that's a place in
Arizona
Oh heared me red rocks in Arizona one
time was driving across the country from
Los Angeles to Texas yeah there's a
place called pica Cho Peak I think it's
like it looks just something like
prehistoric there's a little gift shop
little gift shop at the bottom down
there and I went in and they had
scorpions and lollipops and I was like
oh my gosh this is a giant lollipop with
a scorpion that you can eat you know
yeah yeah I'm like I don't know if does
anyone actually eat these I hadn't seen
the owner of the store I swear to God he
turns around well it takes one with a
brass pair kid he was a veteran who lost
his eye in Nam oh wow reminds was very
nice very friendly but if the owner of
the novelty shop right underneath pit
and there's nothing for miles
Peter Joe peak is still I would love to
have you in the show did he have a ball
in has he not heard of strawberry I mean
come on it's gonna normal strawberry
there was a scorpion we'll never mind
that's much more I've seen those yeah
yeah because why would I eat a lollipop
yeah with a skort with a school zone oh
wait a second see you never know live
chicken a little bit she fared the best
with the fork a from home yeah that's
like an after in before photo comin
heartburn drug being studied as a
possible treatment I'm a little curious
about this because I saw this this
morning they were there pushing our
heartburn medication sometimes
deactivate certain receptors that are
attacked vyek Ovid right reg I know is
there live we weren't ever supposed to
talk about this but it's actually
surprisingly people been talking about
how bad smoking is and I have not no
medical advice here whatsoever but they
did one study in China where they looked
at the people who contracted coronavirus
and it was unbelievably low the
percentage of smokers in comparison to
the director the total population of
China they got and a big reason they
thought is that nicotine actually acts
on the if I'm not mistaken like the a2
receptors that kovat attacked so they
down regulates the sensitivity of those
receptors kovat attacks it and it really
has nothing to attack I wonder if it's
the same thing with a little bit of
peptidase at pepcid ac - smoke is your
lungs already destroyed it becomes smoke
No so I'm not saying you should smoke
flu and let me ask you this question for
everyone watching and we can go through
with the chat but also this is gonna be
our caps of people in the comments
section below you stop shaking
you've restless leg syndrome it does you
need me to gif do you have moderate to
severe plaque psoriasis that's all the
Christmas leg syndrome Beauty this
hardcore pharmaceutical this is my mild
plaque psoriasis normal I'll honor it to
severe it's like well if we say severe
we won't get enough catch a sliding
scale exactly like I don't know you have
moderate what if someone doesn't make
that phone call because I think it's
moderate not moderate just an hour and
then it just gets away from there turn
around moderate severe it's just severe
which I don't like those come what I
asked my doctor shouldn't my doctor be
telling me about there's nothing about
this model there's nothing I can do I'm
sorry patient to severe plaque psoriasis
what about what about pepcid ac give me
a prescription pad I'm gonna write down
some percocet while I'm at it like it's
a speakeasy yeah come on back with the
pepcid ac oh all right we should
probably okay we should probably but I
will say this I I don't hate Western
medicine but if pharmaceutical reps
should be shot at dawn before breakfast
one point when I was like before Brooke
I talked about this when I was early
married and I was defecating in boxes
because I had some stomach problems yeah
turned out it was related having my next
removed and all this stuff like a
probiotic thing
so anyways I'm on there and I go to a
gastrointestinal gist and he's taught
like him he's asked me what am i doing
like learn from my parents you know and
there's this stunner pharmaceutical rep
because hey do you mind if one of this
rep us it's yes don't finish that
sentence I do mine
yes in there at all yeah I don't even
want your understudy there at all
whatever they call it what do they need
they don't need to be there nurse so I
don't know but do you think that any of
this will catch up with Joe Biden the
accusations the allegations of rape the
fact that the media has not been holding
him accountable whatsoever before we go
into any of this with Joe Biden I want
to be clear I think we should hold this
the same standard as we did justice
Brett Kavanaugh so I don't think that
Joe Biden is guilty at this point I have
no proof that he's guilty at this point
but it's fun to act like he's guilty
trolling going on but there is some
information that I think people should
know the real crime here is not whether
Joe Biden well first up if he did it
that's the real crime wave rapes an
actual crime yes it's a crime it's not
like is it this Iceland yeah it's just
crime and not funny crime it's right on
the button crime rapist right there it's
one of those trends that sort of there's
not a gray area being said the crime
that we are witnessing right now is that
a media malpractice is that of them
covering up what could potentially be a
crime and making it hard for people to
investigate whether or not a crime was
committed and that to me is what's so
sinister and I will say this you never
want to attribute malice you know as to
what what can i shocked up to stupidity
but i'll make a case here as to why i
think some foul play is going on you
know if I were if this were a clue I'd
like huh and the murderer is CNN
yeah so let's go to this really quick
glad we're not terror read she talked
about how the reason this was the other
town was she talked about you now that
terror yeah it's different blow at a
party right this is Tara Reid fortunate
coincidence right
well it's spelled differently it is but
it doesn't matter right and there's also
maybe she's not Joe Biden is also being
accused by rosario Dawson ah he just
apparently he had a fetish from Josie in
the [ __ ] cat co-starred may yes it's a
very weird fetish stuff you know
different strokes also he tried to rape
someone from different strokes oh wow
what you talking about Biden he was like
well he he's like trying to always
talking about rape so Tara Reid said in
one one interview in another you know my
mother did call in to Larry King back in
1993 about this and it was sort of
veiled and she said I bet you someone
could find the episode well someone did
find the episode and even though you
can't a hundred percent confirm that
this is Tara Reid's mother the one who's
accusing Joe Biden of sexual assault we
can confirm that her mother lived in
Samuel Obispo we can confirm it's her on
the timeframe where she said that it
would have taken place and the voice in
question has been identified as Tara
Reid's mom by some folks so right now
just to be clear this is not really in
question it hasn't been confirmed but we
haven't heard anyone even deny it I want
you to listen to this phone call Tara
Reid woman who was allegedly raped by
Biden her mother calling in to Larry
King we're bad couple more phone calls
on this very important topic our guests
are former United States Senator Howard
Baker Richard Allen former national
security adviser and Louis Romano of the
Washington Post San Luis Obispo
California hello yes hello I'm wondering
what a staffer would to do besides go to
the press in Washington my daughter has
just left there after working for a
prominent senator and could not get
through with her problems at all and the
only thing she could have done was go to
the press and she chose not to do it out
of respect for him or she had a story to
tell but out of respect for the
person she worked for she didn't tell
her well but these are the people who do
come to the Louis Romano's right the
staff worker who says I want to let you
know about what's going on also the guy
down the hall mm-hmm and a lot of these
people have a sense of obligation they
feel that this public official should be
accountable if it's something
whistleblowers to the president exactly
no the first thing I notice I apologize
for the poor sound it's how bad Larry
King is yeah it just repeats and then
tosses to someone to do his job the city
rose now in San Luis Obispo California
you're on the air okay so you're saying
you were raped and you want to know if
that is a crime correct your honor what
is the legal status on rape it is a
crime Larry it is a crime San Luis
Obispo we'll go to our caller in
Poughkeepsie that's a big legal thumbs
down from this headline says that
Chipotle has gotten in trouble one more
time for contaminated food no doctor
your thoughts on contamination at
Chipotle
thank you for your commentary I will be
back and people act as though he's
providing some sort of value okay so
here's what's really scary after this
the August 11th 1993 broadcast of that
show right disappeared keep this up
because I need to see this really
quickly now here's what's crazy about
this 154 155 if you look at these
episodes right we don't know when this
was removed from the Google Play Store
but it skips from August 10th August
12th I've looked into and keep this up
for a little bit because I can't look at
this on my iPad I looked everywhere else
through these seasons and I couldn't
find a day skipped provided it wasn't a
weekend weather I always actually ring
this is the only one that I can find and
if you look that it goes from 154 to 155
that means they had to change the
episode numbers of the catalog after for
the entire season if they can bring that
down that is so same some people were
saying well CNN had this removed know
CNN actually didn't have it removed but
that's even scarier to me because that
means that Google Play themselves
removed it and someone at Google
alphabet Google changed the entire
count afterward which makes me wonder
what kind of I mean what are they are
they sacrificing children to Molech when
they go out to Bohemian Grove like what
kind of a cabal is there behind the
scenes right they remove that video
though so don't worry it's already good
right yeah yeah some people were saying
there's no conspiracy because CNN
doesn't doesn't do anything with Google
well huh that doesn't you that just
means that Google is in on it with right
it's worse if that's the case it's right
isn't the actor here it's somebody else
that did it it's like oh great now we
have to worry about them too right even
more I always do yeah and if all people
Google should know how the internet
works they think that if you remove it
then it's gone never had net zero
correct that's that's correct from the
1990s yes I hear you use the Internet
right I do not but in the internet
everything is everywhere all the time so
why do they think that yeah just
okay well we'll change the route the
numbers so people won't like nobody
Wayback Machine and so we have actually
said with this evidence which is it's
thin right but it does corroborate what
she says happened yeah right and could
be it could certainly more than we ever
had with Brett Cabot exactly I was gonna
say we've actually we have passed the
point of the evidence that we had with
Brett Kavanaugh we are light-years
beyond that with evidence now for this
case and we're not hearing well and
here's what I understood there are three
potential Biden running mates right they
were in Sunday shows none of them were
asked about the allegation and I believe
it was Tara Reid I was really pissed off
with Anderson Cooper no one asked anyone
anything and this is let's just simplify
this let's boil this down let's be
reductive what happened to me - that
wasn't it higher kind of even every hash
tag me - everything was me - right now
it's nowhere to be found kind of like
black lives matter what happened the
black lives matter that's gone now
none of it there's no me - at all
whereas right now you farmer the
neighbor had with cabinet now what do I
mean by that well how do I say that we
have more evidence here than we have
with Cavanaugh where there really isn't
all that much evidence well with
Cavanaugh we didn't have that much
evidence but we had a lot of anti
evidence
we had a woman Christine Blasi Ford who
came forward and said that something
happened on a day that she couldn't
remember in a place that she described
which police investigated it didn't even
exist her story that she gave to the
psychologist didn't corroborate with a
story that was put out in journals and
and I think it was a Washington Post at
the time and wasn't the same as the
testimony that was provided at the
hearing then there were other women who
came forward who afterward recanted and
said okay that wasn't necessarily true
and the only reason they did that was
because people came out and said there's
no possible way he could have been there
at that time throughout this entire
timespan Brett Kavanaugh was like a
real-life Doug in that a journal for his
entire robbery and several other
instances which is why it was considered
to be at least semi valid as a form of
evidence and gives no history outside of
the accusations that were brought to
light immediately by the media there is
no other history of Brett Kavanaugh
committing any any type of enterprise no
sexual conduct at all nothing the only
time it ever had ever been brought up
was on the media immediately full-on
assault against him this isn't the first
time this happened with Joe Biden
believe you're lying any eyes and ears
he sniffs children he sniffs children he
has biker ladies sit on his lap several
people have come forward before and just
said that they've made her that he's
made them uncomfortable now this woman
claims rape she says I bet if you go
back to Larry King my mom called in and
that goes up and then it comes down
because Google decides not to Evert or
to remove it entirely and then no media
entity interviewing Joe Biden or any of
the potential running mates bring up any
of this there's a lot more evidence here
than we can we not give them as at least
as much credence like as long as that we
gave Christine before there's so much
more evidence and less disconfort
disconfirming evidence but can we not
just maybe raise them to the same level
question about it and say hey yeah
you're potentially one of his running
mates what do you think about these
allegations though they're obviously
false I know CNN would throw it right of
course what do you think about these
terribly false accusations by that [ __ ]
of a woman you know like you know just
just discredit her immediately but they
didn't even say that they didn't they
said nothing about it right for her to
be the spokesperson for the next me to
movement I'm saying it's possible but at
least ask the question if you are a news
agency and you know what you're supposed
to do there is no me to move I know I
know think that's the point it's dead
and I would as a matter of fact the one
thing I will say the silver lining and
this is don't expect people to trot out
false accusations against Donald Trump
this election well that was what was
brilliant the last go-around they
brought out the you know the tape of him
grabbing by that you know and then he
brought out Juanita Broderick yeah
that's right
bill quit most people think of Monica
Lewinsky that's awkward but she was in
love with it she left they we had a
relationship you were raped right you
were raped Juanita what it was raped its
chair he's got like the would need a
card right he's right away no we
shouldn't bring this up anymore
I better be quiet now I think that well
God who knows the media might decide to
make us go away and bring out some false
allegation against Donald Trump but
here's something else if someone were to
come forward let's say right now right
who worked for Joe Biden someone
interacting with Joe Biden say you know
what Joe Biden actually yeah he's kind
of racist he treated me poorly because
I'm a minority you would have to go well
let's go back to the tale of the tape
you can't go into a 7-eleven without a
slight Indian accent Barack Obama is the
first clean children growing up in a
jungle a racial jungle put you back in
Chains now does it mean that he's a I
don't think that Joe Biden is a racist
but if someone were to come forward and
say he thought he treated me with a
racial insensitivity that made me
uncomfortable there's far more of a
track record there then you would have
of Brett Kavanaugh it's the rules for
radicals thing of accusing somebody of
doing exactly what you're doing it
distracts people from you taking part in
the things that you're a fan of Donald
Trump or others of doing right yeah it's
an insane strategy yeah there were me of
evidence to convict him if somebody came
out and said yes he's actually a secret
racist you know yeah he has the hood he
has the whole getup it's in his closet
yeah there'd be plenty of evidence be
like oh yeah all right well that makes
sense you just need a few pictures of
him having dinner with Robert Byrd would
ya yeah that'll happen
pro tempore him at that point he was
fourth in line for the presidency yeah
if here's what a couple of airplanes
went down yeah Robert Byrd wasn't he
wasn't just kind of dabbling in racism
he was recruiting he'll and dent
in a company car the clan sent him there
town very hard to find a Lincoln Towncar
all white it is like Mary Kay you get
enough recruits you get your own Wow you
get enough recruits and you get a car
with a custom burning cross hood we just
use the KKK to a multi-level marketing
[Laughter]
it's really basically a Westphalia I
don't have to compromise my uniform
right and I can get where I need to go
anyway my point is Jo binds a rapist in
a racist I don't think he's either of
those things right I am at the point you
know I used to say like hey we should be
above that I don't know I don't know at
this point for comedy cuz they they
could see that and then they can say no
we don't actually think he is like
there's both they're right we're fine
well at least hold them to the same
standard you hold and by the way the
interviews that happen on the sunday
shows that you mentioned I don't know I
know that there's three I know two of
the potential running mates and they're
both women is the third one a woman as
well
yeah so all three women this was not a
relevant topic a women's issue
God so like there was a guy sitting up
there yeah that's it potentially could
be Joe Biden's a vice presidential
candidate well I don't know you know
exploratory committee yeah yeah quick
question are you concerned about him
raping you
yeah exactly smelling your hair is it
okay if he smells your hair now running
mate for job I didn't diddle you correct
at no point did he smell your collar
yeah alright your thought on sniffing
babies will be back Larry King I'm sorry
Dave Ruben I know everyone really likes
pens I can't think of anyone maybe
Barbara Walters she's one who
trivialized
worse than anyone I think I've ever
success voice the Larry King's got that
I don't know it's easy to imitate voice
that's fun way to search for a way to
condone oh come on I don't know he's
Larry King was the worst guy at handling
the trolls but caller number two calling
in from Tempe you're on the air
Howard Stern's penis Howard Stern's
penis probably by the mmm Howard Stern's
penis do you know anything about that
Senator Byrd no matter what I said he
has to repeat it oh we're gonna get you
some new updates on the coronavirus
kovat 19 deaths and the all cause
mortality rate now again I make no
apologies for the position that we've
maintained here on this show whole table
but before that I know that many of you
of course you're in quarantine and right
now we're seeing that actually it looks
like they're gonna be in quarantine
still in in Wisconsin through May yes
what so yeah all the way through May is
what I just saw there on CNN so we know
that many of you have had your morning
commutes disrupted we do our best to
serve you so I believe we have our
senior traffic correspondent on it's
time for traffic update
[Music]
all right Thomas Finnegan with our
traffic update tell us what's going on
this morning there Thomas
that doesn't sound well nothing good
nothing good okay uh thank you very much
all right this isn't a traffic update
with Thomas venturi reporting
[Music]
how did he make senior correspondent or
respondent so no one seen Thomas no well
no he's the guy one of the groans though
yeah he is he's on the front lines
definitely the guy one out there by the
way next to the tornado do you want a
new trip because we've been calling
obviously everyone on the front lines
working in hospital sure as heroes right
there on the front lines working in
hospitals but you know what a synonym is
for that now furloughed yeah yeah we've
just destroyed decimated the health
industry here in the United States a lot
of people don't know this that people
are just they can't stay in business
because we were waiting for a surge that
never fully came and an idea of
flattening the curve was to make sure
they were equipped now they're equipped
but they can't provide non-essential
services they can't make money and I bet
who knows what's gonna happen with the
healthcare sector and they're not doing
well visits so a lot of these doctors
offices are just sitting empty like okay
well I do it sick talk videos and stuff
yeah so pediatricians are just sitting
around waiting for more kids to come in
but they're not come don't come in for
the regular scheduled stuff so and
that's also a big reason that the
testing isn't very high because people
were told not to go in they're afraid of
this virus and so they don't want to go
in and get tested and then they said
well why isn't there more unless you
force people to come in and get tested
but you're not gonna have more testing
the good thing is now we have several
different municipalities that have done
antibody testing and I know this isn't a
hundred percent accurate okay I'll do a
graph maybe next time when we do this
show but we have New York City Santa
Clara County Los Angeles County
miami-dade County and then Chelsea
Massachusetts near Boston okay many many
many many thousands of people now would
have done random testing sampling for
antibodies and all of these different
populations these are in small cities
every single one has come out showing a
four to over six percent infection rate
meaning far higher than we initially
estimated every single one let me go
back New York City Los Angeles County
miami-dade and I know Chelsea if someone
knows of another large-scale antibody
test that's reliable
send it in because every single day
every single one has now revised their
death rate to 0.5 to 0.1 keep in mind
95% of those in every single study
conducted
involves people over the age of 70 with
comorbidities so the chance so it is the
flu right now the actual death rate is
far more communicable
but it is the flu let's be really clear
now some people are saying though there
might be some false positives for those
antibody tests and so cooking might be a
little bit high all right okay let's say
that but let's take a sliding scale here
at my my left your right maybe I should
do it in reverse my right your left okay
the flu is about 0.1 percent right death
right and then the projected death rates
that we had was between three and I
heard as high as seven percent New York
they said seven percent let's call it
five percent so point one flu seven
percent here okay here you have to be a
long way away however always call the
science deny if they said well you know
what it seems like it's more comfortable
to the flu than what they're claiming
it's going to be right let's say that
there are a few too many positive
antibody tests right now and it's I
don't know point five percent let's say
it's point seven percent which no one is
saying by the way now no one is saying
the death rate at this point mortality
rate could be any more than point seven
percent most people are saying it's
really more like point one to point five
percent okay
the stoopid krazy amt science denier she
said it was closer to the flu zero point
one versus five percent over here
science foul she all these folks are
their projections take your little dot
put it on that sliding what is this a
stick graph what do you call it a graph
graph guess what the crazy anti-vaxxer
climate denying anti science folks who
said it's more comfortable to the flu
got it exponentially more correct than
the experts and of course i meant you
should get vaccinated I'm not an
anti-vaxxer of course I'm not saying
that there's no such thing as climate
change I'm saying you right labeled
these people as anti science peasants
who couldn't no you should trust the
experts you guys were off by thousand
yeah yes it's incredible and the cats
really out of the bag on this like like
when we just when are we done with this
how much longer does this charade need
to go on where people say we have to
stay close and we have to do this
through May and we have to keep our
businesses shut down and hospitals and
every every time you see CNN up there by
the way they're talking about
oh crap here's another one because
restaurants are closed people aren't
buying as much food right in restaurants
and so the farmers are having problems
now and the supply chain is starting to
break down we really need to reopen the
economy it's like dominos duh there's a
great video with some people in in from
I think Los Angeles two doctors who
talked about the patient that they've
actually seen and they've condemned
body tests and I think we have it up at
laterals credit come I will tell you
this right now in our neighborhood okay
we all live in about the same
neighborhood we can go to Costco yeah
and go shopping right we can drive
through or pick up at Shake Shack at
Five Guys at Dunkin Donuts right you can
you can drive through or pick up Dunkin
Dunkin sorry that's right they want to
move the doughnuts no no no you wear
that around your neck for all time okay
you contributed to this obesity epidemic
thus increase the mortality rate
Jefferson Cova do you own it you will
forever be Dunkin Donuts you know what
if nothing else I'm gonna call you
doughnuts so I can go to Costco I can
drive through Shake Shack Five Guys Taco
Bell Dunkin Donuts but I can't support
my local bakery no I can't support my
local mom-and-pop restaurant you tell me
how that makes sense yeah it doesn't
make sense at all especially when you
can social distance in restaurants and
you can sanitize stuff
I mean God forbid you're telling me the
fork they're putting on my table isn't
sanitized right I'm putting in my mouth
every other time I go to that restaurant
look and see ya CNN did a segment this
morning about how this is all affecting
black small business owners right it's
affecting every small business owner
yeah like oh it's a weed we don't need
to make this some sort of racial thing
is this is a negative thing for people
who can't everybody yeah for everybody
and everybody's experiencing this at a
different level but small businesses are
experiencing at a high level isn't it
kind of funny that right now they say
this is affecting black people in my
Norton they want to make it a racial
thing but then if you Judy we've gotten
in trouble where we've said I've made
jokes about you know sickle cell and
yeah quarter like they catch sickle
cells like oh that's racist and that's a
biological fact can I have a KD in blood
I didn't realize that there are so many
hereditary disease is exclusive to
Akkadian bloodline violated genetic
testing at the same enough black people
sickle cell let's be honest they don't
really want to talk about genetic
predispositions they want to talk about
food deserts and they want to talk about
black business owners they don't really
want to talk about diseases that might
affect people of a specific right
lineage of a specific racial makeup I
think that might be a little helpful no
don't talk about you've got a few you've
got a few little grim reaper looking
cells inside you they do
there's sickles always waiting some
people call it a sickle cell I call it a
Sling see
a little bit of a coronavirus update
here that I think is important we didn't
want to lead it with that because we
thought rates was more interesting and
I'm getting a little bit tired of
coronavirus I bet you at this time man
we couldn't have timed our quarantine
months more perfect because after this
you guys are they'll be free and next
show I'm going to lick a popsicle stick
and leave it on here look wait do you
have the covent I'm pretty sure we all
have the coke I'm pretty sure we all had
curly that's pretty sure we all had it
well that's the problem
anybody testing is tough but you know
what the best thing to do right now is
isolate the sick and the elderly and get
it over with
you know inject bleach into my temple
[Laughter]
don't even get me started on bloody
radiation all stuff because I'm people
say are you giving medical advice no I'm
just saying it's an actual thing they'll
hit you it's real thing but okay before
I move on to covent update Donald Trump
real this is the kind of thing he does
rescrew his supporters Donald Trump's
ego supporters he said I was being
sarcastic you were not being sarcastic
no you said something that was
reasonable by the way until you misspoke
you should have said is there some way
to get the disinfectant to like a
cleaning in the lungs with the real
doctor listen you probably should have
let the doctors do the speaking you
introduced that you introduced the topic
bring out the expert that's what these
press press press house nice sound press
house briefing I would say like no it's
rather breath out things and they would
say did you mean White House press
briefings no I was there's so many
fevers the changing all about the White
House website to press house right and
so people have been coming back at the
same if you regret saying what you said
on Friday no I don't like I regret I
regret nothing because people were going
out there saying I think it was governor
Whitmer from Michigan saying you
absolutely should not drink life so I'll
find me a quote remotely close to Donald
Trump saying you need to drink Lysol no
he didn't say that what the media went
forward with what they used was
completely it was media malpractice it
was journalistic malpractice totally
taken out of context that being said as
we said on Friday Donald Trump sometimes
speaks like an idiot
yes and for him to be defended by his
supporters saying the media has taken
this out of context was granted might
have been a misspeak he would rather lie
and say I was being sarcastic
then just own up that he made a mistake
well do you think that the media the
people in the media actually think that
he means put Lysol in your veins no of
course not you know you don't think they
think that no I think that they just are
so blind that they actually don't
understand what words are coming out
like they're trying to misinterpret it
but no I don't think so okay I think I
think I think someone at CNN called
Lysol like can someone at Lysol went wow
I mean this way a lot of people aren't
watching the press briefings a lot are
they had great ratings but if you heard
about this most likely the only way that
you heard about it was CNN saying
something about injecting something into
your body well I wasn't I made it all
the way through the CNN is
inconsequential that no one watches
their ratings but this base Miller else
is reporting at MSNBC all over the web
right and that's how people would have
heard it not from Donald Trump himself
so everyone is chloroquine lady yes the
entire media is the person we actually
thought was stupid right and turns out
she's a murder and by the way that was
the idea if there have been increased
calls to poison control Metro real
really not sure I bring this up actually
I'm not shaken yeah we can bring this up
as a fact check we had it in here in the
show map this morning and then we
decided to go a different go the
direction of RuPaul's Drag Race with
some stories from back in Detroit so a
new Israeli global study shows that this
is something it's been across the board
and they can't necessarily explain it
that there's a rapid increase with
coronavirus it peaks in a sixth week and
then it declines in the eighth week
regardless right of lockdown policies
and you've heard us talk about this
quite a bit because if you look at
Sweden
they're not worse off for example they
had no lockdown and there's a reasonable
difference between the two where you
should able to split the difference
where you either lock down everything
and you quarantine the healthy which
makes no sense then historically you
don't quarantine a healthier quarantine
the second
then there's the other approach of
Sweden where you don't do anything and
you leave all schools open you don't
really change the way of life a whole
bunch I think there's a middle ground
which is you quarantine the sick you
quarantine the vulnerable and you allow
the healthy to go forward right here's
something else it's pretty interesting
William Briggs he actually wrote that
flu and we talked about this flu
pneumonia deaths are being misclassified
as coronavirus deaths and here's
something that's really telling we've
talked about this how all of a sudden
flu deaths went to zero right right just
this is here miraculous Morocco zero a
lot of people said well maybe that work
here of social distancing and you heard
me say hold on a second this is
happening before social distancing in
the sense that those flu deaths and
pneumonia deaths went down in February
or early March okay so that would've
been before social distancing even if it
went all the way through mid-april
social distancing wouldn't have really
kicked in until about now just a clear
but the all cause mortality death rate
is significantly lower this year really
in last year yes and this is going back
to January so what does that mean for a
second that means it's been trending
down since January long before lockdowns
began and it's only been declining more
I think we can bring this up here this
is from the the William Briggs study so
that means all cause mortality well what
would that mean - I mean flu pneumonia
heart attack stroke right cancer -
wreath all cause mortality is lower why
because of any of those other
comorbidities in any other year which
would be ready this is a stroke death
this right yeah the deaths due to
complications with diabetes this is a
death due to uh complications with
hypertension are all being listed as
kovat deaths just like all flu and
pneumonia deaths are being listed as
kovat death it doesn't make any sense
that this year our overall mortality
rate is significantly lower and it is
significantly lower across the board on
the all cause mortality rate unless like
we saw in Pennsylvania where they took
just 200 Cova deaths off the books like
you saw in New York on the flip side
where they added 3,700 coronavirus
deaths without being tested by the way
they just assumed that it was present
and I understand it there are some
complications here where yeah well if
someone has cancer and they get that
they're going through chemo and they're
doing okay and then they get the flu
well maybe the flu didn't kill them but
there is a split those right it's not
all of them
go on the register what will be
registered as a flu death yeah typically
you go woho ii what was the more severe
condition what was the condition that
was more likely to kill someone
is it the chemo is it the fact that this
person has stage 4 melanoma or the fact
that this person has the flu
no what was going to kill them and
evitable it was a cancer so they they
look at those are death rates in this
country aren't all that accurate and
when you look at these numbers now that
show us ok coronavirus peaks at 6 weeks
and goes down by eight weeks regardless
of containment and then you look at the
all cause mortality rate being lower
that is something that should concern a
lot of people because I think these
books I'm not a doctor I want to be very
very clear here not offering medical
advice but the books are cooked yeah
it's not the nurses that are doing that
it seems like the guidance that they're
being given is either intentionally or
unintentionally juicing up these numbers
right from CDC or whoever whoever is
putting out the guidelines on how to
track these things yeah and you you ask
yourself like if these guys are pumping
up the numbers why why are you doing
that and I think it Briggs actually
makes the point down there it's like one
of the possibilities is that they're
projections were so wrong they're trying
to nudge the numbers up a little bit see
like see we're not as dumb as you think
we are the projections right and the
other one is that it's just bad
reporting right they're just doing a
poor job of really classifying what
people are dying from right I don't know
which side it comes down on but I don't
think it's doctors and nurses that we
should be frustrated you're not saying
that either but I think somebody needs
to look into why are we camp now but
they're also so fine at a higher level
so as a financial incentive ranaut you
listed death as a coronavirus
coronavirus related death yeah look at
some of the relief that's meant to go to
hospitals specifically some of it is
allocated for coronavirus deaths when we
can fetch again Reggie and bring it up
this is some and it was in USA Today
yeah you don't have to be a doctor to be
able to do math right it's actually a
good thing people outside of the medical
community are checking on these numbers
and going yeah yeah seems a little
strange yeah right and in the cool thing
too about this graph and the same the
reason I say cool is because it's great
news if the Israel Times report is
correct because it peaks at 6:00 and
dies down at 8:00 it was global they
looked at all of the different countries
who had different responses to this
virus even to you know South Korea
Taiwan places like that and they put it
with some of the most hard-hit they used
New York just as itself and not just the
United States and all of the graphs did
that all of them right right across the
entire planet that was awesome
great great thing because hopefully it
just burns itself out right and that's
yes the arc well listen we know that
it's killed by UV light it is we have
the best Sun their absolute best bring
it up again real quick that's the
overlay that yet more patients hospitals
get paid more if patients list are
listed as Ovid 19 on ventilators that's
right specifically on ventilators right
now yeah and none of these what was the
u.s. what does that USNS comfort us has
comfort us call oh yeah yeah they
weren't even close to capacity with
their beds yeah almost all of these
hospitals that have been built up they
haven't been used at all right hospitals
right now are furloughing and laying off
workers they're not full they're not
filled to capacity so this whole flatten
the curve well we we did it we may be we
may have flattened a curve that wasn't
really maybe going to happen because now
we've destroyed an entire industry of
health care workers and unfortunately
you do have to go to the doctors who are
actually treating patients listen I'm
not disrespecting doctor foul at all and
right he hasn't seen a patient in 20
years and the theoretical and the
practical what happens in the real world
are very different things when you look
at doctors were actually treating
patients right now on a grand scale
there does seem to be a chasm between
doctors who are uh now don't just take
doctors in Lenox Hill don't just take
doctors in New York City but doctors
even in California doctors in Wyoming
doctors in Texas if you take what they
are seeing and what is going on in their
hospitals and compare it to the
projections that you saw from the World
Health Organization or what dr. Fauci
said was hunt was undeniable here's the
thing if you look at the there is no
denying right now okay here's something
about which there can be no disagreement
it wouldn't have been humanly possible
for the United States to have 2.5
million deaths it's not possible it's
not possible understanding the death
rates that we understand now yes not a
possibility
unless the entire population consisted
of yeah 95 year-old with diabetes it's
not a possibility
yeah well yeah going back to the sort of
kovat hospital funding a lot of the most
grants most discoveries and science that
are grant based tend to happen right
when the grant money is just about to
run out right yeah or at least like Oh
what are you something we might need a
little more money to check into X
z right and so if yeah there is a profit
motive and it's clear it's clear that
it's being taken advantage of by the way
his views a little skewed because he
actually gets money from his sugar daddy
named grant and start running the
bookcase it's the unintended
consequences of this and when they pass
the cares what is it the cares act that
they did for unemployment there's P P P
and then there's a cure it basically
what is it called moral hazard right the
you're trying to get people off of
unemployment but you're paying them so
much that there's no incentive to do
that the same thing can happen in
hospital situations right lab studies
where you just incentivize some behavior
and unfortunately it causes people to
run that direction and that very well
could be the case in hospitals I don't
know that is I think they just suck at
making predictions like this I think
they're just not good medicine
necessarily moves there were many
contradictions and they fly on a four to
seven percent death rate well they're
right and they're very bad us from the
beginning yes people like us from and by
the way it wasn't just based on a hunch
it was based on other epidemiologists
who were working around we posted other
voices that like where people were
saying there's this is far more
prevalent than people realized that
mortality rate is far lower these
projections are incorrect now we know
that the skeptics the contrarians
were right let's be clear about that
because the skeptics the contrarian Asst
could be right on the idea that the when
the left tries to say hey they're just
like the climate deniers go you know
what
yep yep the people who said there's no
way we're gonna have 2.5 million dead in
the United States there's no way no how
I want you to remember that and go he's
the same guy who's saying that the Kyoto
Protocol won't curb emissions because we
shouldn't just China yep I'm that denier
yeah that guy put me in that category
yep I said no way 2.5 million deaths no
way 5 to 7% death rate it's horseshit
I'm the same guy saying Montreal was at
Montreal agreement Kyoto Protocol now
it's the Paris Accord 3 clear - clear -
protocol Paris Accord yep I'm the same
denier now just like with kovat I didn't
say it was a hoax I was saying this is
something that needs to be dealt with
appropriately right there needs to be
the appropriate scale in relation to the
threat that is exactly what we are
saying about climate change there needs
to be an equal and appropri
it responds to the scale of the threat
and shutting down the world economy you
know how difficult this has been by the
way you know how difficult this has been
right now for everyone here we talked
about the economy shutting it down what
do you think would happen if neo
environmentalists had their way globally
and these same people like aoc were
saying I think it's a great thing that
oil is it a net negative if these people
had their way what you're experiencing
right now is actually child's play
compared to what they would experience
in the third world with a green new deal
or the Kyoto Protocol actually being
signed sorry my bad Paris Accord I came
let alone in the new world you think
that you've been thrust out into the
cold knows you cannot imagine what would
happen so think coronavirus the leftist
response would happen in the economy now
apply that to the entire globe that is
the Paris agreement so yeah put us all
in the same boat yeah well we all know
that the people who have made these bad
predictions who have been proved wrong
publicly are gonna be around when there
is some kind of second wave or if
there's some second and they're gonna be
oh man same things they're not gonna
lose their jobs I think that's the best
probably the most track one of the most
tragic things about this whole deception
is that it could happen again by the
same people to the same audience right
we have to hold these people accountable
remember their names and when they pop
up again on your screen remember that's
the guy who said it wrong it's a pretty
example if they're playing with somebody
else's money
yeah it's someone here free let's say
someone here said all right listen these
are our projections for the profits for
LA doors Crowder and we said okay all
right we're gonna hire some new people
we're gonna make sure we bring quarter
black geared up ok we'll pay people a
little bit more we're gonna get some
health insurance going on here as
opposed to a health sharing program
we're gonna be okay good we do it and
then someone goes oh wait sorry I was
off by how much well you're actually
making 90 percent less profit oh yeah
you're my guy who was supposed to
project though your fire yeah 2.5
million deaths which by the way could
not have possibly been decreased by
social distancing we know that now it's
not because of social distancing it's
because your numbers were wrong and now
we're looking at under six and a
thousand deaths you were off by it
what's the percentage on that I mean
it's that's I mean astronomical I can
put a percent of done it because I'm not
a math Asian he's not here today but
that being said it should be oh you're
fine
tired all right well in the letters
playing with our money yes our
businesses are shut down yeah right how
about we put a freeze on everyone in the
government right now
Senators Congressmen how about that how
would a pay freeze how about they
experience the same kind of freeze that
we do okay you know what you get 1,200 a
month ooh yeah I like that
I think this is also like the lesson for
the general public is that this is the
playbook
right next time something comes around
it doesn't have to be a global pandemic
that they use right if government is is
is bent on overreaching and growing
which is pretty much the only thing that
government does they can use the same
thing and say well we have this threat
called climate change it's going to kill
a hundred thousand people this year two
hundred thousand next year we have we
have to forcibly close things down and
make everybody do their part to avoid
this catastrophic thing right it's exact
same thing yeah you can come out and say
the exact same thing about climate
change hey I'm gonna do a live read here
for a sponsor of course my lawmaker is a
black rifle black rifle copy that comes
Lashkar into the promo code cutter you
get 20% off but today sponsoring the
whole show the studio a lot of credit
studios is brought to you by clock
radios
what better way to wake up then to the
sound of your favorite local radio
personalities clock radios can make it
happen
clock radios tell the time and play
music all at once I know what you're
thinking well I have a phone for that
well for a limited time if you order
using our promo code we'll throw in a
cordless home phone absolutely full
price just go to imdb.com type in promo
code radio 2003 today that's imdb.com
promo code radio 2003 oh thank you clock
radio
I usually every morning yeah will do
well well do we have some chat to get to
they are given and then we'll have get
well we'll close it out with papa
Crowder stories but I want to have
Goldblum before that so yes we have a
couple of chance okay hold on a second
let's bring you let's bring me hit me
with a couple of chats kerbals there we
go now I'm on all right this one comes
from Jay what are your thoughts on
Twitter of Twitter and YouTube forcing
companies to take down their videos on
uv-light studies and devices that are
developing to combat kovin 19 well I
mean is that a trick question what do
you say I just repeat the question back
to okay here's one thing that I will I
have to be very very careful because
don't want to provide any misinformation
that being said everyone here you all
know that we have a protocol that was
given to us by a doctor with supplements
that we take to try and protect
ourselves and improve our immune system
as best possible dr. Phil he's great yes
yeah he's great now I I don't want to
dispense any medical of us but I will
say this research coronavirus go search
what receptors they attack look at the
mechanism of action and see if there are
any supplements out there that could
potentially help you with PubMed as a
great is a great portal it's a great
resource for you and talk with your
doctor there are things out there but I
can't say that the risk of being banned
now that being said UV light blood
irradiation which is where you would
actually irradiated with UV light and
then re injected in the body so it gets
carried around to the entire bloodstream
yeah um is I think it was referred to as
the antibiotic time forgot so before
antibiotics they use this there are
clinical studies that have shown that it
works in patients with hepatitis C
certain viruses it reaches the clinical
thresholds for reducing the viral load
now and that's that's been done with
many different viruses and I'm not
exactly sure infections entirely we
haven't done it on coronavirus but the
idea that getting UV light in any way
into someone's blood as an effective
mechanism of killing some kind of a
pathogen is not new it's not a novel and
it's certainly not quackery
so the fact now I'll tell you what is
quackery I'll tell you what is let me
let me be clear it's not wrong blood
irradiation has been a technique that
has been used quite a bit for a very
long time okay so it's not incorrect
I'll tell you what is incorrect that
corona virus cannot be transmitted
through human to human contact which is
what the World Health Organization
tweeted out so here's the problem if we
have to rely on the World Health
Organization in YouTube and Google and
Facebook are going to be the arbiters of
truth and effectively with corona virus
the World Health Organization is going
to be their Snopes or their Washington
Post and they have verifiably gotten it
wrong one two three four times no doubt
no doubt about it they've gotten it
wrong that's a scary thing because we
have to trust the authorities who we
know are wrong and their minions their
lackeys their toadies won't allow us to
get out any other information in the
face of the World Health Organization
what do you do with that well is it
scary let me just one
one other thing one other thing that
really really scares me here with radio
okay and I think we have this we can
bring it up as an overlay reg can send
it to you I got a complaint from someone
in Germany that was a violation of
German law oh really so now we have
China the government of China and the
government of Pakistan I don't know if
this was the government of Germany but
back with radio ours we used to have to
deal with the FCC okay right and it was
kind of a game of cat-and-mouse where
you could say okay craphead but you
can't say I took a trap silly rules what
we sort of would play and you know I
danced up to the line when I was
syndicated on radio we thought man the
beauty of new media is we won't have
those kinds of censors anymore right
we'll have to worry about the FCC but at
least with the FCC you knew who your
enemy was at that point now it's
actually far worse because you are
censored by the outraged mob cancel
culture just means society at large is
the new FCC and they are far more
stringent because you could get away
with all kinds of jokes that might be
offensive that the FCC didn't care about
as long as you didn't say that naughty
words Yeah right and the problem now - I
would compare that we've always been
really concerned about our rights being
taken away by government rightfully so
because historically you look at the
triangle and historically you look at
the Romans you look at the you look at
the Greeks you look at the Ottomans you
look at governments those were the most
powerful entities that had the ability
to take away your rights but now I see
just like with radio and the FCC the mob
is actually far more dangerous what's
far scarier to me than the government's
ability to take your take away your
rights is the mobs demand that they do
so I'm not saying that all these people
are Nazis I want to be really clear but
when we often say how could how could
that happen how could how could World
War two how could the Holocaust happen
hold on a second is it that crazy of a
leap to go from officer officer officer
there's a mom with her son on the swing
get her take her to jail
take her at gunpoint to jail is it that
far of a leap from that to you'd an
officer jiù jiù someone is in a park
with their child and you are going to
call the cops on them that's what's
scary to me now now that the government
does it right but that people demand it
the power of the mob is intensely
terrifying for me it is and you have to
make sure that if you're up somebody
after you have to speak against those
kind of things right you don't just sit
by - the person who called the police
and right just let them get away with it
that's socially not okay I don't care if
you're trying to stop what you think is
a 10% killer pandemic okay we have
rights we have Liberty and if we give
that up in this case week it's gonna be
taken from us forcibly later on down the
road for some other well the point being
taken it's being taken right now by a
mob of people it is bring it up even
yeah so this was the tweet can can you
read the tweet I can't exactly see what
my tweet was but this is an official
complaint from someone in Germany yeah
it says hello we have received a
complaint regarding your account at s
Crowder for the following contents the
tweet yeah the tweet text is it's
becoming clear that it's becoming clear
that scarier than the government's
ability to take away your rights is the
power of the mob to demand it okay and
that was come on I said it wasn't in
violation with German law but typically
that usually comes from an official when
they recognize when they actually say
it's not in violation of the law of this
country which by the way Twitter you can
bring that down is not a good enough
standard Twitter I don't give a [ __ ] if
it's a violation of German law Chinese
law Pakistani law you shouldn't be
abiding by their laws should be abiding
by the laws of the country that you
founded because if your goal is to open
up democracy and dialogue for everyone
you can't be beholden to China's law
because guess what they're murdering
Hong Kong protesters okay guess what
they're silencing and disappearing act
whistleblowers it's not enough to hide
behind the law you don't get to do that
you're an American company that's the
law you obey dummies all right yeah but
whether it's the FCC or the mob or just
the general culture it can't it doesn't
have any power if it can't get inside
your head so the only power that we have
right now is just to not let that
culture pass right so the censorship
culture or the culture of
self-censorship where you're constantly
having to second-guess yourself or self
censor yourself that that's the culture
and you don't and you don't have to let
that in your head right now well and a
lot of the show does that a lot of the
show pushes back on the restrictions
right I think there's some times where
we do stuff that we wouldn't otherwise
do because we're pushing back against
these restrictions oh no I wouldn't
necessarily always do this but you said
I can't you don't have the power to say
that so guess what
I'm gonna do an apology video yeah of
everything what you're pushing back on
the restriction and I'm sorry guys I
apologize that I said no way there's 2.5
million I apologize that I said that
several months ago and never walked it
back I am sorry I am deeply sorry
know how troubled you are so here's
another one speaking of which just let's
get to something then we'll have pops
probably a great story from his days
back in Detroit but I love this this is
it's not necessarily something that you
have to know this morning but I want you
to take it put it in your chest pocket
and take it with you for all your days
until Wednesday we have another story
like this for you yeah Jeff Goldblum was
on is this show is it RuPaul's Drag Race
it's if it's not that then it's it's
some kind of a drag queen hole in it I
don't really know what a drag queen is
anymore honestly when you consider the
transgender they don't go to a most
ninety percent of them don't get the
bottom surgery right they don't get the
top surgery they don't go through
hormone replacement they just identify
as a woman and they dressed like a woman
category a drag queen just dresses like
so I don't know how am I supposed to
know it's moving target self identity
man and I have a story about a drag
queen actually in a burlesque show with
my wife I'll tell that after but a the
story burlesque dancers hauling who says
no evidence so far the contracting
coronavirus makes you immune to second
infection jeez okay well we don't know
that that's true but we do know that for
at least a couple of months let me ask
this question historically does it
typically mean that you have a better
chance of fighting off a second wave
means a better chance yes not true with
all viruses nobody had to phrase it the
worst possible you know who is armed
corrupt liars and YouTube come at me so
I think we might go a little bit late
today but my wife's idea was Valentine's
Day when we were in Grand Rapids
Michigan to go to a burlesque show Oh
imagine my surprise okay I found out
that burlesque show it's basically
there's strippers who didn't make the
cut
it's strippers for less how many tattoos
and it's like it's it's rockabilly
strippers so you know they put on a
little bit of tiger army and go out
there and shake whatever's there and you
know no one's the wiser because it's
alternative so it was really great there
was unfortunately this lady who was a
burlesque and she'd nipple pasties
pasties what he kept a station oceana
monde
and it was really unfortunate because
she was one of those very overweight
women who managed to not have any like
other words she had like the body of a
fat woman but the chest
Kevin James and so it was like it
couldn't be later
yeah it was just really really
unfortunate Wow so this is going on and
on my all right April s show and then
all of a sudden they bring out whatever
you know Desiree these stupid names all
these dragons and it's six for looking
like black linebacker oh yes with clown
makeup and I don't this person maybe not
be transgender was it the burlesque show
and it's a dragged and started singing
like lip-synching something I don't
remember what it was because I just
didn't want anything to do with it and
then takes his little what do you call
this uh with there you go I know you
know that so fo and starts going out
into the audience oh no no no and makes
a beeline for me now my wife and at the
time a couple of friends were there and
they're laughing this is really funny
yeah but this sort of you know drag
queens and I could smell it I'm like oh
this is gonna be funny I'm gonna loosen
him up but it ended very quickly because
I didn't give a face like oh I'm shy
yeah this person came up the drag queen
rhinestone whatever Desiree rhinestone I
think might have been the name
it could have votes desirable jewel I
don't know does that that well uh oh
yeah but comes out and starts you know
doing a happy birthday mr. president to
me but it stops so and I'll tell you
exactly why this person could read on my
face at read in the whole room got
uncomfortable yeah it wasn't like this
you know this person comes out with a
bow and me you know some something like
this like know what happened this person
made a beeline to me starts pointing at
me and the audience our school but my
face once this Desiree rhinestone came
up my face wasn't like my face was like
this apparently my wife described it
afterwards I was so disgusted I might
hear trail to my shoulder and went on to
the next
oh honey because the whole crime I've
seen you walk out of movies for far less
sir you should have gotten up and left
so that was my experience with a drag
queen story time but this was a dress
they read where the wild things are so
Jeff Goldblum was on some kind of a drag
queen show I don't know if it was RuPaul
or what I don't want to get it wrong and
offend the drag community which I
understand is differing from the
transgender community maybe but this
spurred outrage from people for being
Islamophobic and I just it it is a
combination of wondrous things roll clip
are you religious may I ask I'm not and
to be honest this outfit really
represents the importance that
visibility for people of religious
minorities need to have in this country
isn't this an interesting wrinkle though
religion that is anti-homosexuality and
anti a woman does that complicate the
issue I'm just raising you know thinking
out loud maybe being stupid but no no I
think you know drag is always shaking
the tree so to speak and there are so
many different layers to this
presentation and if it was ever going to
be done this is the stage where it's a
complex issue I have my own misgivings
about the way that LGBT people are
treated in the Middle East and at the
same time I am one well no you're one
here over there you just be ups that you
be done yeah he says that like he's
coming out yeah we know you're also in
Whiteface so okay don't think just
because you toss on a dress and a couple
of sparkles that you get to appropriate
that's the interesting my non-existent
culture because let's be honest I don't
really have one but um oh and isn't this
an interesting wrinkle
and it seems that you've had to use some
double-sided tape because a a penis
finds a way he doesn't even realize he
doesn't realize that he's stepping into
the Twitter halo yeah it's entirely
logical it's it's a reasonable question
no one would have bad an eye that person
came out and said I'm Mormon they would
like oh well how does that work when
you're part of it at a very conservative
you know it would have brought up it's
not as llama phobic it's like it's
completely accurate it is yeah it's it's
llamas llama accurate right it's exactly
what their religion would do to this
person if they were in that country he's
like huh well here let me be really
clear some fast facts you're obviously
like the Bible the Quran condemns people
of Sodom for their homosexuality so want
to be really clear now that's a little
bit different that the Bible the Quran
doesn't outline specific punishment but
we've talked about this before you look
at various ADIZ penalties for
homosexuality ranging from beatings and
life imprisonment to being thrown from
building they'll beat the gay out of you
they think yes here's another one Saudi
Arabia recently they just beheaded five
men for being gay and Iran in Yemen also
hold home homosexuality is punishable by
death so you can find the most red state
you can imagine go on down to Idaho and
find me someone there who's going to
throw five gay men off of rooftops
that's a slow week forget it wrinkle but
you're mad with Jeff Goldblum for
bringing it up right yeah when he says
ha he asked a question like are you are
you a practicing in this religion at all
and he's like huh that's really
interesting that they would have that if
he just incredibly asked I'm surprised
you're not dead how did you make it out
well it for some reason reminds me of
the so there's some UK Democrat Paul D
democratic liberal Democrat politician
doing fasting during Ramadan yeah so
it's like what does what does this
person on RuPaul's Drag Race and the
politician fasting during Ramadan I
think they're doing yeah right
yeah it's helping them and something
like really they're just taking on the
religion and acting like it's some kind
of comment right yeah I would have a lot
more respect if they would just come out
and say yeah it's it's pretty much a
hellhole over there right now they kill
anybody they think might be gay
well this is also the idea these people
are and these people I mean the LGBTQA
AIP community are bullies now what do I
mean they pick a fight where they know
someone can't fight back they put on an
American flag burqa with rhinestones as
a drag queen / transgender something
they would never dream of doing from
their homeland that they identify with
as a religious minority from the Middle
East they do it here in the United
States so that they can be little
character assess and they denigrate
people like Jeff Goldblum for bringing
up a totally fair question right that's
a bully they know that they have the
pulpit here they are doing something
they would never punch up and do this in
the Middle East they would never go and
do that in Iran or Yemen or Saudi Arabia
but they'll do it here in the United
States and bring the Twitter mob with
them against Jeff Goldblum because why
they know that there are no
repercussions for it they know that
there's no accountability for it you go
do this go do this in the public square
right now in Palestine and Yemen in
Saudi Arabia in Pakistan hell you know
what do it in Qatar see how it ends up
for you boom gives us something
something like reason in this whole
scenario yeah and then and then the
person the guy in the burqa is just like
you know what I had my stupid thing I
wanted to do Jeff Goldblum isn't that
good enough for you can I just do my
stupid name but that doesn't know what
he's doing I don't know why he's doing
what he's doing the guy the actually the
guy said you know I don't really like
how they're dress like so why don't you
think nobody it seems like nobody was
offended Jeff Goldblum felt like he was
waiting into really unsettled waters and
was like I don't know am I being stupid
here and they're like no no you're not
but now the Twitter outrage mob is like
no you we are offended for this person
even though they aren't we're reporting
a crime that was committed against them
that they don't even think happened
right it does make any sense to me why
this is a thing oh it makes perfect
sense to me no I know we have to offer
calm I just wanted you to see that yeah
because you can see he starts off
thinking like oh I'm a clever guy yeah
this is insightful and then he
immediately wishes he can take it back
oh isn't this a clever wrinkle here no
no no I mean maybe I'm stupid
scrotum you have a wrinkly scrotum no no
been real has this already been posted
on Twitter it has okay yeah yeah so he
thinks he's being woke but he's not
woken up for everybody else when you get
doped in the woke which is amazing he's
not woke enough in trying to bring up
the idea he's trying to protect people
like that from being crucified right
yeah
it's like a sport over there you can hit
like five bull's-eyes in a row people
work out to throw people off of a build
a decapitated em worker game is a
warm-up act yes the emcee comes out our
National Anthem oh yeah yeah you know I
don't know exactly what and then the
Midler is with a sickle
now on to the real show the drag queens
head into the net they get a free
slurpie
everybody Shaq always misses those
dragged by the way we're gonna bring a
notification bell hit all notifications
if you're subscribed than YouTube
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot and
if you can't be bothered to do that we
just have new videos they go up every
single week at the YouTube channel
steven crowder 8 p.m. Eastern and please
do consider joining mug club this entire
month the rest of the month from moco
quarantine $30 off flodders care.com
slash mug club and the last day is going
to be Thursday big old livestream but
now actually a lot of you have said you
would love to hear some more stories
from my horse I can't wait wait the Pops
way hold so I raised in Detroit Detroit
proper and when he's been the show you
guys know him you love him so it's time
for some stories from Papa Crowder
oh geez I appreciate its the copyright
okay I appreciate the flagrant disregard
for the hold on a second might get
alright well this hopefully this is
gonna be a good story here I have no
idea if we're gonna hear this is like
showing your parents how to use an
iPhone or the first time right now you
push the button son right before we go
into a store with my father do we have
one more chat maybe my dad can answer
one yeah we got one more chance one call
the [ __ ] on YouTube angle that more
toward you during the audio wait here's
my father he's right there your fault
into what I stopped you played Joe Biden
in sketches you aren't actually here all
right that's comfortable
all right so this one comes to us from
Tower Cube tower q good morning moto
that would like my question for you is
simple what's going to happen in North
Korea now that kim jeong-hoon is mi a
how does this affect the West I don't
really know that it affects the way what
concerns me is I will say this because
of sort of the the I guess sort of the
the what I'm trying yeah the turbulent
waters with shall we say and the
relationship with North Korea it does
worry me that this is happening right
now but I am obviously I was elated to
hear that kim jeong-hoon is actually the
most alive and well person yes he is
there is that's what you think you've
stopped living people yes yes didn't you
say his sister is worse isn't that the
deal she might actually that's what I've
heard I don't know who's following up
behind him but I do know that the doctor
that the Japanese newspaper said called
him obese he's done Oh didn't obese man
stuff yeah very very fat perfect health
there's so much of Dear Leader's since
my residency so now it's almost like
having a frog with a cotton ball but I'm
sure he's dead and you know he's fat so
very fat I've heard that his sister
might step in which she's apparently he
was worse than a sorry yeah he was worse
than his father worse than his father
initially though like everybody thought
all right maybe he's gonna be a little
more moderate you know he wanted to Phil
killed the uncle his dad wanted to be
you know a little more his dad wanted to
be Suge Knight and he wanted to be like
- [ __ ] yeah that's what he wanted yeah
this is a reference for our audience yes
he wanted to pull the strings behind the
scenes his dad Kim jong-eun one of the
notoriety so he was willing to try to be
more brutal in the reputation and then
if potentially let's say his sister if
then you have a girl in North Korea
who's trying to prove something and she
has a lot to prove because they're true
rap well I mean does she like Dennis
Rodman as well I have no I really hope
so
guarantee you he'd take a crack at her
wouldn't you think this guy wouldn't
like to have an soon on his bed post as
a notch Carmen Electra via a Fox and
Whoopi Goldberg this is not a Whoopi
[Laughter]
starts to fall off yeah it does I get
like not having a type look man I was in
a you know it was it was hard it was
drunk it was tough right and stop it
down how Rodman got his groove back he's
like sister at Darrow will be
well I don't know that that huh no three
or I don't know god help it yeah think
about that for a second Rex you're one
of the best basketball players of all
time and we're getting Ted Danson sloppy
seconds we will see you obviously
tonight we'll see you tonight what do we
have life advice tonight and then of
course tomorrow we'll have a full just a
full normal show Dave room is gonna be
on the show
good morning papa Crowder you know
people wouldn't send they want to hear
some of your stories and I kind of
touched upon this briefly before but I
wanted you to be able to tell it so
first off set the stage for people who
don't know you were you were born you
were raised in Detroit born in
California Raisins oh that's right born
we're in Sacramento yeah born in
California on an Air Force Base came to
Detroit before I even knew it right so
well no letting a year two years here
and was it Detroit was it Mount Pleasant
was no not a suburb before I go through
the trip yes but we'll go back to it
tell them the story that you told me
about the guy at Kroger oh that's a clip
okay all right just yes yesterday yes I
got a Kroger and it was about 60 40 40
percent people wearing masks a week ago
now it's almost a hundred percent yeah
yeah and you'd employees patrons
everybody's walking around in masks and
I go through and I do my self checkout
at one end coming out of the store
everybody's got masks at the self-check
at the exit is a guy about 6 6 300
pounds with a lit stogie in his G with a
Hardy screw you look a mosquito chaser I
said where was this inside chrome stuck
it in the cupholder there's so many
statements
I'm a guy who probably had a fight with
his wife I was just looking for someone
else to like come at him like I don't
care milk and eggs honey but I've taken
my stove and no one said a word you know
he was a mountain of a man okay so you
were raised in Detroit proper and then
oh he's on for the Detroit bits everyone
well no I just want people to know so
you were raised in Detroit because a lot
of times people say they're from the
TripIt they're not really from Detroit
and then you played hockey at a very
high level and you've been well you
played at U of M and you were very high
level he too got a scholarship and then
yes uncle about starting my uncle played
hockey but not nearly as a high level
but when you were young brother your
older brother my uncle played hockey and
you were both pretty athletic I mean
back then it was unheard of for people
to be training and living the kind of
life that you did you were very into it
that's true
and then what is the focus I wasn't a
guy that played a lot of sports I played
one as best I could
right yeah but then well he says that
but I remember we went to the batting
cages in Grandin Ontario and we had some
people there love family friends lovely
but they did baseball raw no they did
baseball not professionally but they
played by level ball and my dad was like
ha no I what yep so he's being humble
here yeah I didn't get any of these
that's what he means by the way I was he
kept them all for himself kept them all
for yourself so but he was what he says
that but other kids are maybe in the
Little League baseball or football
whatever Stephen want to do stand up
when he was before yeah I know
impressions I was a flop so but he's but
he's great at jujitsu he doesn't worry I
will everyone knows you know even
Brendon tore your biceps I'm comfortable
here so anyway but the point is so you
were doing this and then contrast that
with your father let people know about
your dad to set up his story yes
definitely
well they didn't play sports you had to
go out and earn a living right and he
was career military he was a career
fighter pilot so all he ever did and you
want me to tell the story about when he
came home one day no but tell us a story
about your dad like in general he was a
guy who didn't exercise at all didn't
play sport six to maybe 230
2:35 launched smoked of drank drank sure
drank a lot he was Admirals Club the
actual Admirals Club no.1 the officer's
club the gross but yeah at the base
where you would have several whiskey's
sometimes before flying claimed he was a
better pilot after a scotch no I would
tell him science is against you I'm
better I'm sharper err dare I'm on my
game with one scotch so he was so this
is what's flying over your head folks he
was flying every day yeah yeah he wasn't
a guy who was he was training pilots
who's flying every day was a full
colonel very high level but again I just
want to set the stage we're now contrast
your brother at the time well how old
older brother about 18 and so he's
playing junior hockey and he's he's
really good he's yes pretty pretty high
level at that point and just very
athletic very angry to hear he had a
late growth spurt yeah yeah he was he
was had a small man's complex and a big
guys body it's a bad combination
his at 16 he was five six 130 and he was
lying about that an inch and 10 pounds 4
by 8 yes he's 6 to 1 95 is a kid you
can't do that to me attitude right yeah
ok so my dad comes home one day from the
base after a day of flying and who knows
that the officer's club how many
scotches and we're out playing in the in
the neighborhood all the kids are out
there and it's kind of like picture
Sandlot yeah yeah hanging out and my
older brother probably shouldn't be
playing with the younger kids but he was
out there you know kind of cocky the big
bully in the neighborhood so you thought
the old boy comes home I think he was
driving the red GTO at that time and
he's wearing what they call pilots call
the green bag you guys weren't during
the sketch the the top guns one zipper
up the front pockets on the legs and in
those pockets goes your keys your watch
change whiskey rocks so your lower legs
are encumbered with all your stuff you
name it you got patches up here we don't
carry a lot up here so you know piles
out of the car and my cocky older
brother says because we were racing up
and down the street would hey old man
let's see what you got
my dad crushes out a cigarette he's
about 50 at this point full colonel just
left the officer's club crushed out a
cigarette who knows how many that did
and he lines up in the
they say from here to that car which is
you know our street wasn't that long
there's also he was what was he what
shoes was he wearing oh of course
combat boots yeah yeah like those yeah a
little bit different yes yeah yeah
flight boots my brother you would you
got to think at 18 year old boys nearest
peak right he's probably in high-level
hockey player I don't let it great shui
training sure yeah so they line up and
my brother goes into some silly tracks
dance or something that you know he's
already
yeah and and the old boy just kind of as
they said crushes one out stands
alliances someone say go if it takes off
it wasn't my brother by at least a house
and a half every kid in the neighborhood
but he handled the dramatic he didn't
come back and fist bump or beat his
chest he just walked off into the house
thorough beat down and witnessed by the
whole neighborhood and all you hear is
this jingling of keys and he just takes
off down the street my uncle saw your
brother didn't ask for a rematch no
there's not challenging anymore well
thank you so much for anyone else but in
the time we'll have you tell the one
where you get a dart put in your head
bathroom so you could keep it in his
head until his parents got home and
[ __ ] jokes with so much everybody
we'll see you tonight
and of course use the promo code
quarantine at lettuce credit.com slash
mug club you get $30 off we hope that
we've been of service to you thank you
for tuning in we will see you tonight
[Music]